The magnanimous offer with all the kings and his military force of Britain
fought against the Saxons and as though there were many more noble than himself,
yet he was 12 times chosen their commander and was as often conqueror.
This is a quote from the ancient text known as Historia Britain on,
which was one of the oldest records of king office life story.
We've all grown up watching movies and reading books about the legend of King
Arthur Young man poles.
The Magic Sword.
Excalibur from the stone and a wizard named Merlin guides him into manhood as an
adult's.
He established the legendary knights of the round table and ruled over Camelot.
Future generations would look to him as the first king of the British empire.
However,
well everyone knows him by name.
Few people know the whole story behind the man who became the legends.
Harold biographics.
Today we aim to uncover the truth behind King Arthur of Camelot.
Yeah,
okay.
During the fifth century,
the Modern Day United Kingdom was called Britannia.
The Roman conquer has had been driven out of the lambs and the ancient Britons.
They were left to govern themselves without a central government,
the country,
it was plunged into a time known as the dark ages.
Several Celtic tribal leaders declared themselves the king,
but there was never one ruler who governed them all.
If this reminds you a little bit of game of Thrones,
that's because George Rr Martin got a lot of his inspiration from these ancient
stories of early Middle Age war and conquest.
As you might imagine,
many of these kingdoms within the British isles,
they were at war with one another and this made it impossible for anyone to
settle down and establish any new art or culture.
There's a lot of mystery surrounding that time because very few people were
bothering to keep a historic record of daily life.
Almost everyone was illiterate from the peasants all the way up to the nobility.
Christian clergyman.
We're the only ones who knew how to read and write,
but they often isolated themselves from the rest of society in favor of devoting
their lives to theological study.
Without a central economy,
citizens and Britannia did not have money in the form of coins or bill.
So rather people were using a barter system to trade goods and services.
Most peasants were farmers and they grew enough food to feed themselves,
but even within this barter system,
people were still expected to pay taxes to their feudal lords in the form of
goods and labor.
Oftentimes,
if two kings were fighting over control of the land,
peasants had to pay taxes twice in one year.
Also,
without a proper education system,
people believed in magic as well.
Incredibly superstitious.
While Christianity existed,
many were still practicing the ancient pagan traditions.
It was during this unstable time when Arthur was born without any written
records.
We don't know the exact date of his birth,
but we do know that he was conceived in tins of gala,
which is on the coast of Cornwall in 2016 and archeological dig at tentacle
reveals that the city held many of the lavish luxury imported goods along the
coast of Cornwall.
At the time,
it would have been a town bustling with activity as boats sailed in and out of
the harbor.
All of his father was a man named king with a pen dragon.
Hey,
let's do the after a beautiful woman named Lady Egg rain,
but she was married to his rival,
Lord gold up according to legends,
Penn Dragon osteous inhouse wizard,
Merlin D'acosta Costa magic spell.
He wants it to look like gold law so that he could trick a grain into having sex
with him.
Of course,
modern historians believe that Mellon was not a wizard at all.
There's actually one of the last remaining Celtic true.
It's how the time druids were thought to have magical powers and a connection to
the spiritual world.
The druids lived their lives being one with nature and practicing herbal
medicine.
They weren't known to be incredibly.
Why isn't what some of the most intelligent people of the time,
Kevin Penn Dragon waited until Lord God while left on a business trip and then
he appeared before lady a grain disguised as a husband.
Considering that we know the magic isn't real,
we know that Mellon could not have cast a spell to focus appearance.
It is far more likely that if a pen dragon took a herbal potion from Merlin in
order to help him violator later.
Lord called while I was horrified to learn that his wife had been raped by an in
pasta shell.
Mutli became pregnant with Penn dragons baby.
This illegitimate child was the boy known as Alpha Lady Green did not want to
raise the baby and no one wanted to claim responsibility.
Marlin felt incredibly guilty for his part in all of this and knew that the boy
was actually a prince.
He took pity on Arthur Rhodes,
chose to raise him as his own son.
Lord God,
Ahrens lady agreeing would go on to have their own daughter and that would be
office half sister Morgan.
The druids were not the only ones who were thought to be magical.
In most cultures around the world,
women who lived alone,
we're often accused of practicing witchcraft.
A young woman named Vivian was known as the Lady of the lake,
but instead of being a frightening older,
which she was described as a beautiful fairy who lived under water.
Now we know that she wasn't a ferry of course,
and that she was just a woman living alone in a cottage near a lake for years.
The lands.
They were filled with watery lakes and Marsha's Christian clergyman belt,
their monasteries on small islands.
And the only way that people could travel there was by boat or by walking along
causeway is that were built over the water in the 17 hundreds.
This land was drained of water to utilize the farm lens.
But it wasn't until recently that modern archaeological digs uncovered a huge
amount of INH swords,
axes,
shields,
um,
uh,
and tools that had been thrown into the water.
Ancient Britons had a tradition of making an offering to the lord of the lands
by tossing their weapons into the lakes.
And Marsha,
it's because of our reputation as a magical fairy.
Vivian's lake was also a spot where people would throw their swords and weapons
in exchange for her blessing.
One day,
Vian discovered that someone had left a very different kind of offering on her
doorstep.
It was a newborn baby boy who had been abandoned by his mother.
She decided to raise the orphan child is a Ronan's named him lance laws.
Merlin was wise enough to know that the lady of the lake wasn't a farrier tall
and it was entranced by it Vivian's beauty and strength.
He fell in love with her and pleaded for her to give him a chance.
Vivian said that she would consider Merlin's proposal if he taught her
everything he knew in the more mystical versions of the story.
Merlin toward Vivian,
how's practice magic,
but you know it's more likely that he was actually showing her how to become a
drew it.
In the end,
they say that the lady of the lake traps melon forever.
Of course,
we know that if she's trapped anything,
it was his heart.
They fell in love and live together in that cottage on the lake.
Since Vivian was raising Lance Larson,
Merlin adopted Arthur,
the two boys would have grown up together as brothers.
You have all heard the epic tale of how young Arthur was able to pull the sword
Excalibur out of the stone and people drop to their knees.
This ended all of their ongoing battles in order to recognize him as that one
true king.
Unfortunately,
we now know that this version of the story is total fantasy,
the warring kingdoms.
They continued to fight one another for control of the Lens.
During Arthur's youth Lonza lots and Arthur,
they practice dueling one another from an early age.
Arthur sword was called many names including Caliban and Excalibur.
Other versions of the story leave out the stone completely and say that the lady
of the lake gave Excalibur to off that according to a researcher from the
University of Wales,
Rachel Bromage,
the name Excalibur may have similarly arisen at a very early date as a generic
name for a sought.
After all there they hadn't had an endless supply of weapons that were thrown
into our lake.
Since everyone bartered for suppliers during the dark ages,
it would only make sense that Vivian would dive into the lake to retrieve as
many valuable weapons as she could offer and monster lost have the rare luxury
of practicing with these expensive swords from an early age and they were
already skilled fighters years before they became nights when she was a
teenager.
I bath his half.
Sister Morgan wanted to become a druid as well,
so she began to study under Merlin,
she and the nickname Morgan la fe or Morgan ferry.
But this time author had no idea that Morgan was actually his half sister,
the two teenagers,
they fell deeply in love.
Merlin forbid the two of them for being together,
of course,
but he never revealed the secrets that they were actually siblings,
but just like any rebellious teenagers in love of trying to give them a pot,
only made their passion grow stronger.
Merlin realized that he needed to reveal the truth before it was too late.
By the time he was in his late teens,
after became one of the most skilled warriors in the land,
and you gained a massive amount of respect from other nights,
King Pan Dragon and his wife,
they never had another male heir to the throne.
Merlin at finally revealed the truth to offer that he was actually the prince
and the true success into the crown,
but this family drama,
it had to be put on the backburner because the Saxons began to invade Britannia,
the Saxons,
the ancient German people,
and they couldn't help but notice all of the chaos going on over in England.
They thought that because of the Roman empire was gone,
maybe this was their chance to take over the land for themselves according to a
ninth century riser us.
Then in those days,
Arthur fought against the Saxons with the king of the Britons,
but he was commander in those battles.
None of goes on until it's 12 different battles across all of Britannia wow.
After it was sent to a fought and conquered the invaders,
this would have taken years of dedication moving from place to place until all
of the Saxons were driven out of the British isles.
Soon enough off his name.
It's spread across the lands.
After gaining a loyal fan base,
Arthur revealed that he was the illegitimate son of King Pen Dragon.
The people of all these Celtic Kingdoms chose to bend the knee to author rents.
He was crowned as the once and future king
off,
built his own castle and Camelot's,
which is said to be located in modern day whales,
often becoming king.
Everyone now knew who authors parents were and he could never marry his half
sister Morgan,
so he therefore married a woman called lady Gwen of Aaron stead.
She became his queen.
It is said that she was one of the most beautiful women in the lands,
but it's like many royal marriages.
There's was one of duty rather than love.
Morgan got married to a man called King,
lot of Orkney reader of Norway,
so she became queen and went on to have a son named going just by the fact that
they now knew they were siblings often are and Morgan were still in love with
one another.
They could not contain their passion and continued this forbidden romance behind
closed doors.
She became pregnant and gave birth to their son.
Moderate.
Once loss had fought alongside Arthur during the war and he was celebrated as
being one of the most skilled nights in the land.
He continued to stay by off the side as a Lord in office course and married a
beautiful young woman named Lady Elaine Lancelot were to participate and
jousting tournament and became an undefeated champion Queen Gwynna via.
I could sense that King Arthur was not loyal to her,
so she enlarged slots began having a secret love affair together during his
battles against the Saxons often gathered his nights that he knew he could
trust.
He built a large round table in the Great Hall of his castle.
He chose this circular shape so that no man would be in a seat that was more
important than the others.
Dozens of men would gather to discuss politics and plan for future quests.
Arthur and his knights,
they went on countless adventures together.
One of the most famous quests was the search for the holy grail,
which was said to have been the comp that Jesus Christ drank from during the
last south hub,
according to the 12th century writer shredding on Detroit.
That grail was made of the finest pure gold,
and it was such a precious stones of many kinds of the richest and most precious
in the earth or the sea legend has it that wondering from this cop would heal
all wounds and guarantee that it's owner would be granted eternal life.
Many historians believe that the legend of the holy grail was simply putting a
Christine twist on the Pagan myth of the cauldrons of plenty.
But that did not stop these men from attempting to find this mythical item.
Lancelot and Lady Elaine,
they went on to have a son named Galahad who was said to have one of the purest
hearts of all the nights in Britannia.
As the story goes,
Galahad was the only night we had a true enough heart to touch the grail,
but he died attempting to find it.
Most scholars believe that the Holy Grail is just a myth,
while others say that it is a real artifact waiting to be discovered.
So anyway,
Morgan,
the fake found out about Lancelot and Gwen avails love,
and she revealed the truth to offer just by the fact that everyone was chasing.
I want another this revelation,
it's still outraged off and he felt completely betrayed by his best friends.
Authors nights they stormed lance lots,
chamber runs,
he was tortured and killed.
Queen [inaudible] was allowed to live,
but she had to witness her true love die as a result of the affair
off his son and also nephew more knew from an early age that he was a child of
incest,
but he would never be able to reveal the truth to the public that he was the
true out of the throne.
When he grew up,
more was knighted,
but he had to pretend to be only his father's nephew.
His older brother go,
Wayne ascended to the throne of Norway,
but it was also very loyal member of King Arthur's round table.
Like many roles here with a product of incest.
Mordrid was known for being a little bit more than crazy.
He has an incredibly violent temper during battle Queen Greenwich.
Erin [inaudible] never had any children together,
so there was never an outage and the throne of Camelot moderate grub hating his
father and he came up with a plan for how to take the throne for himself.
Heartbroken over the loss of her beloved Lancelot.
Queen Gwenivere spent most of her days alone in the castle.
One day,
King Arthur was away on one of his many quests.
Mordrid saw this is an opportunity to seduce Gwen of and it worked.
The queen saw this is a second chance at happiness,
so she ran off to marry this young man who she thought was her husband's nephew
in this case,
so we could say,
is it good that they're at least not blood relatives?
Anyway,
in his father's absence,
moderate sat on authors thrown and declared to everyone in the kingdom that he
was now the new king of Camelot.
When the return time he saw more dreaded taking the throne.
This betrayal is what sparks in the battle of Kamlan were father and son,
fourth one another in the battlefield.
They were both mortally wounded,
killing one of that that went off the Diet.
His body was taken to an island called Avalon to be buried.
Now,
just before we get into the legacy,
I do want to point out,
but the day this video went live is indeed April.
The first of 2019 hang off was not a real person.
Okay.
April fool's day,
we,
sorry to say,
but the character of King Arthur was a complete work of fiction and so was this
entire video.
The legends we now know today came from a British,
your story and called Geoffrey of Monmouth,
who write the 11th century book called the history of the kings of Britain.
According to archaeologists,
Dr. Miles Russell,
the legend of King Arthur is really based on five different individual leaders
in the ancient world.
The first was called Embracia saw early on us and he was actually one of the
people who defeated the Saxons and battle.
There are also elements of the true stories of Rehmann rulers like Constantine,
the great ans magnus maximus.
Dr. Russell says,
Arthur's Beth marriage,
midlife crisis,
and dramatic death.
These are elements that have already happened.
When you take them away from Arthur's story,
there is nothing there for Arthur.
The character Jeffery gives us is an echo of other people.
I suspect he's trying to create a Celtic Superhero.
The legend of King Arthur became even more elaborate during the century when a
French poet named Detroit out is all of that romantic elements to the story.
He is the one I did the details about Milan and the lady in the lake and the
romance between lady going Advair and Lancelot.
Despite the fact that these texts were not historically accurate as the fact
that they contains half truths and how fictions was enough to confuse future
generations.
Kings and Queens in Briston spent over a thousand years believing that King
Arthur was real.
They saw this as the original establishment of the British and bought even King
Henry the seventh named his first born son Prince offer and Declan's that he
would bring on a new authority and age these sides to balance,
to legitimize the legends,
to glad that the stories were true historic facts,
even commissioned arounds able to be built in his own castle so that he could
live like the legendary king.
The physician on liking effect continued well into the 1800 sweat Queen Victoria
commissions,
an entire wall of the raving room of the parliament building to show the story
of King off his life and his rise to power even well into the 20th century.
The Nazis believed that they needed to avenge the Saxon ancestors and the Nazis
to let society set house on their own quest for the holy grail in the 1930s it
wasn't until very recently that archeologists and historians of questions,
the existence of King Athens have chosen to write off the story.
It's just a legend,
despite the fact that it's a work of pure fiction hitting off the,
continues to capture the imagination of people around the welds and will
continue to do so for years to come.
So that lets us know in the comments section,
if you were fooled by this video or if you just a bit too clever to fall for it.
Maybe if you're watching this on April fool's day,
it could be a good thing to send to friends or family.
And as always,
thank you for watching.